i'm sure you certainly know at this
point this september marks 10 years
since the series finale of entourage i
got you your own plane what are you
talking about
oh
whoa
what did you do all i could
rest is up to you
you got a plane will take you anywhere
in the world
you're amazing
you ain't seen nothing yet i've seen
what you've said you're open to reviving
it maybe turtle would be the celebrity
today and vince would maybe be his
driver do you really think you had a
connection yeah when you go you're good
people's man in the last 10 years we've
we've grown we've matured and evolved as
a society i like to think we're a little
kinder with how we approach certain
topics so if you were to revive
entourage what changes would you make to
it to make it work in 2021 it's a tough
question because i think you know
societally speaking we're dealing with a
lot of serious issues and we're taking
things a lot very seriously which is
important but there's also a very
important role for comedy you know what
do they say like comedy is tragedy plus
time you know i think we don't want to
lose our ability to laugh and make fun
of ourselves and not take life so
seriously because
uh you know
laughter is funny and and
you know poking fun is an important way
to find
you know truth at the same time and
entourage you know was i think a really
spot-on comedic reflection of our
culture at the time and so i think if
entourage could continue to
take a look at the world and be honest
about what what is
it's going to be funny too
[Music]
you